sponsored by step finance your go
to d5 portfolio manager on solana
bitmex the og crypto derivatives platform
and the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys anna welcome back to the lay ohio plan
show so as you know this podcast is sponsored by
the cryptocurrency exchange bitmex so a huge
shout out and a massive thank you to bitmex
because on this show we talk about all the things
you're sort of not allowed to speak about we talk
about authoritarianism censorship freedom and of
course bitcoin so without bitmex we wouldn't be
able to bring you such valuable and really crucial
information during the times that we're living in
so joining me today we are joined with trainee
priest broadcaster and conservative commentator
calvin robinson calvin welcome to the show my
pleasure to be here thanks for the invitation
yeah my pleasure it's great to meet you we only
recently connected um but i love everything that
you're doing online and we're going to get into
all of that but for those who don't know who you
are just give us a brief background oh i hate
that question because i don't know where to go
i i present on gb news i used to do a lot of
talk radio stuff i write in the telegraph the
daily mail occasionally the express and
the times about issues that i think are
important in our society such as education
faith and culture let's start with the faith
part because something pretty interesting came
out a couple of weeks ago um and you're a trainee
priest but from what i understood somebody i think
it was the was it the bishop of edmonton stopped
you or blocked you from being ordained so can you
just give us some more information about it yeah
it's a challenging one because they the bishops
have all the authority there are no procedures
to follow there are no policies so you can't call
them out for example in an employment tribunal or
anything like that but what's happened is there's
been a sustained campaign against me by the bishop
of edmonton who doesn't like my political views
not my christian views not my theology but my
political views the bishop of london has been the
person that he's been complaining to consistently
and she is the person that's ultimately
ultimately responsible for a person like me
and has therefore said we're not going to
take it forward and this is after you know
four or five years of discernment plus two
years uh reading theology in oxford uh all
paid for by parishioners you know little doris in
the pews has paid 20 grand to send me to college
uh and at the end of it they've said no but what
i've just learned is that they've never planned on
sending me into a parish you know i did a subject
access request so we all have a right to see
any data about us that's held by a public body
and i saw emails going all the way back to
before i even started training suggesting that
they did not like my views and did not want to
see me ordained so the church of england doesn't
want to see you ordained because they don't agree
with your political view so what what's so bad
about your political cause tell me one example
is calvin does not believe in institutional racism
i mean that's a very broad statement to make but
what i've said is that you know when the cred
report came out the cred the sewell report didn't
find any evidence of institutional racism but
found very very it found many elements of racial
disparities and it put forward suggestions on how
to solve them ideas actions going forward to help
make this country a better place i was like
yeah let's follow those actions let you know
let's stamp out racism we all want to do that
but people are campaigning say actually well
it doesn't say that racism is institutional so
we can't follow the advice like it's that word
they get stuck on which words institutions so you
so you basically you don't think that the uk is
institutionally racist no i think there are many
elements of racism and there are many nasty racist
people and those people need to be held to account
but that doesn't make the entire country racist i
can't think of any country that's less racist than
the uk it's one of the best places in the world to
live as an ethnic minority we have protections
in the equalities act you know we have equality
in law we can do whatever we like if we work hard
enough but i think people use institutional racism
as an excuse it's all the system is against me
i've been held back because of the color of my
skin i can't get anywhere why should i bother
it's like no get your head down work harder
you'll make something of your life and these
priests are white yeah always white middle-class
or metropolitan liberal elite types you're saying
no you're wrong on this issue of race calvin in
fact i've sat down with the bishop of london and
she said look as a white woman i can tell you
the church is institutionally racist i'm like well
that's not my lived experience surely your whole
your whole stick is that you want to listen to
the lived experiences of ethnic minorities why not
mine is it because it doesn't meet the narrative
is it because it doesn't align with your views is
it true that you really want to listen to us or
is it just you want to listen to the ones that
you can pat on the shoulder so you're a good black
boy you know you're you're going along with the
party line i think it's a new form of racism
actually i think that's racist to say to you
so you're obviously mixed let's just make
that clear for those that don't know so you're
mom dad so my mom's white my dad's black okay so
isn't that a form of racism someone to say to you
you can't think like that you're you know you
must think like this a white person telling you
i've had it all my life you know it's the left
tend to think that being an ethnic minority
i have to vote for left-wing parties i have to
hold left-wing opinions you know this whole idea
that we're being that we're all one homogeneous
group of non-white people explain being i think
blackened minority ethnic or bipoc in the us this
idea that anyone that's not white belongs to one
homogeneous group and they almost vote like think
alike and talk alike i find that racist that's
very patronizing because we're individuals and
we all have different opinions different thoughts
different religions why should we subscribe
to the left's narrative on what we think
and i think it comes down to control and power
because if the left say we are the party for your
particular demographic you have to stay in that
box and anyone in that box has to for us that's
how they get into power but how has this narrative
been able to infiltrate the church of england well
the bishops are very i use the word metropolitan
liberal lead because i think that's true they are
all white middle class people who are in an
echo chamber of people around them that think
alike and talk alike therefore they're not
exposed to different thoughts and opinions
therefore they have a moral a sense of moral
superiority and it's not rooted in scripture
it's not rooted in the religion it's rooted
in their politics they think they can make
the world a better place with their narrow-minded
perspective and anyone that speaks up against it
is cast aside or silenced or shoved out and it's
not representative you know the people in the
pews the people in the congregations are small
c conservative but for the most part because
this country is small seed conservative for the
most part uh most of the clergymen are mostly
conservative some of them aren't that's fine a
good mix but the bishops they are the gatekeepers
and they choose who gets let in and who doesn't
get let in something to answer to they've got
no accountability so what have you done as
a result i just exposed it just you know i
i gave all of the emails and documents from my
subject access request that shows the bishops
um campaigning against me i sent it all to my
friends at the mail on sunday in the express
and said you know run with it take whatever
angle you like just put the truth out there
and they have done and i don't think the bishops
have liked it but it's opened a lot of people's
eyes to what's going on in the church so let's
go into that i'm trying to understand what is
going on in the church and i saw a video of you
talking about how the church is less interested in
promoting jesus but more interested in promoting
other types of woke religions right um so break
that down for me what is the church focusing
on now rather than jesus they've forgotten
about jesus so you're much more likely to hear a
sermon on climate change man-made climate change
yeah oh gosh yeah all the time brexit and how
evil it is trump even though it's nothing to
do with clergy in the church of england um the
bishops stood out they spoke out against these
things they spoke out against dominic cummings the
government adviser they spoke out against brexit
they kind of moralized the vaccines said to be
a good christian you have to take this vaccine
the coveted vaccine of course the one that doesn't
work um and i think that's inappropriate and i
think that's harmful because it's breaking down
trust in an institution that had a lot of people's
trust and was supposed to be there to support
people you know talking about the pandemic the
church went above and beyond the uk government's
advice and closed all the churches not just to the
faithful masters not just to people who were lost
and looking for hope during a scary time but they
closed them to the priests too it said you can't
even go in there to pray for your parishioners
i think that's a great evil that's a great
wickedness that will take a lot of people a long
time to get over yeah the pope was even pushing
the vaccine um and i'm not as religious as you i'd
say i'm spiritual in some ways um but from from
a spiritual standpoint i felt that the coercion
um just felt morally wrong and the lies felt
morally wrong you know i'm all about freedom
and i think people should have the right to um
be free to worship which i think that was sort
of shut down last easter and then 2021 so um how
how could how can they how can the church justify
that level of sort of the lack of ethics there
i think you're right freedom of choice is the
key we should have the freedom of choice not
for freedom of worship but also for freedom of
choosing to take a vaccine if we don't believe
that the vaccine has a good efficacy and i don't
think it does then we should have a choice
whether we take it or not and we've seen
cathedrals say you can only come to services
if you are vaccinated that you have to show
a vaccine path to get into god's house that does
not seem appropriate you know jesus christ would
be among the lepers but people who are on backs
aren't lepers they're just people who've made
an ethical choice um i think that you know people
keep showing me profile pages from the wef website
that the archbishop of canterbury is amongst them
oh no um so i think there is a clear bias there
that needs addressing i think what's kind of
frightening is the church of england for just for
some context for this i don't know is obviously
one of the oldest institutions um in the united
kingdom um and so how has this left-wing woke
culture being able to infiltrate that and also
how dangerous is that for just the united
kingdom at large it's systematic so just
like with every other public body they've taken
over through the long march of institut through
the institutions so we've got key positions
being taken over in the church of england we had
one woman who was responsible for selecting
all the bishops so it used to be a long time
ago that you know the queen or the the lord
the more the monarchy selected the bishops
but then the monarchy became constitutional
so the prime minister selected the bishops and
put their names forward to the queen who just
signed it off but then with gordon brown not being
a church of england uh member himself didn't want
that responsibility so he took a step back and it
became a civil servant's job to select the bishops
that civil servant was left-leaning metropolitan
liberal elite and became the gatekeeper and now
we have a whole house of bishops that think alike
what are the dangers of a church which focuses on
climate change trump equality and quote unquote
equality rather than jesus well it's it's found a
new religion the religion of woke and the dangers
of that is that when people need help when people
need to know that jesus christ is there for them
throughout their suffering when people need
someone to look out for their spiritual well-being
when we're locked away and isolated and lonely or
people are dying without seeing their loved ones
when they need that support it's not there for
them because the church is preaching about other
things it's got a new focus and you know people
say if you knew all this if you knew the church's
work why were you joining it well i i believe
that this church is christ's body on earth and
i think that's an important thing and i wanted to
help at least be a part of a moment to drag the
church back towards christ and towards the bible
but i've realized i can't do that from within
what does this mean then for um issues which
which the church would usually take a stance
on like homosexuality abortion what does that
mean what's the stance now yeah so people seem
to think the church has changed its stance on
these issues but what's actually happened is
the church has stopped teaching about these
issues they stopped talking about these issues
you know there's still christian doctrine that
marriage is between one man and one woman and it
always will because it's in the bible they can't
change that however they've stopped having the
conversation so people think oh well the church
is lackadaisical about this anyone can you know
do whatever they like now and that's not the case
it's still the case that the christian doctrine
promotes sex within marriage for example
um again people think oh you can you know
you sleep with her you want them that's fine all
of these things have become non-issues abortion
the church should be arguing in favor of pro-life
and protecting the the life of the unborn child
again people think that the church has shifted
its stance on that it hasn't on any of them it
can't on any of them because they are biblical
scriptural there are people within the church
who want to see it change they want homosexual
marriage they want pro-choice or pro-abortion
and they want uh promiscuity but these things
aren't christian tenants so they cannot have them
how far do you think this is gonna go it could go
you know at the moment the church is having a big
conversation about homosexual marriage for example
and when i bring this up let me just make be clear
i'm not against homosexuality i'm not against gay
people i'm just saying that a christian marriage
is between one man and one woman united on the
eyes of god for the purposes of procreation and
and go forth and multiply and all of that
it's not to say that some other people
in different lifestyles are bad people
or wrong people or should be ostracized
everybody should be welcomed in the church i
just want to make that clear because people think
when you're promoting one thing it means you're
against another and that's not always the case
but it's very very clear what the
christian stance of these issues is
so let's go into this whole woke narrative because
i i feel you know it's clearly infiltrated the
church of england um it's infiltrating even even
you know even something is ridiculous like netflix
you know you can't watch a movie without feeling
um like you're being indoctrinated by something
um so i've heard people say the reason we now
have this woke church um it's sort of become
a religion and the reason why they have
that is because there's a lack of religion
um you know society's become so secular and people
feel like they lack purpose you know religion sort
of grounded them um what are your thoughts on
that why do you think people are becoming so woke
100 people need something that people have a void
in their lives and they're looking for meaning and
the church hasn't been there to step in and say
here we are you know christ is with you so the
church has taken a step back and in fact closed
its doors so people have looked elsewhere people
have joined blm protests or extinction rebellion
or glued their faces to the floor or you know
attacked police horses and joined these groups
because they have a sense of belonging and it's
the same with a lot of issues we're seeing so
you know the whole trans debate the reason we've
seen so many people suddenly come out as trans
when it used to be such a small minority it's
because the moment you say you are trans you've
got a family you've got a community you've got
a whole cohort of people there to support you you
feel like you belong to something it's a movement
and now you don't even have to do anything
physically you just identify as well so it's
so much easier to gain entry into that community
it's so true um if you identify as a victim
then you get all this attention and all this
love that's all people want a bit of love it's
mind-blowing i think um what's interesting you
mentioned blm so i'm guessing you don't like
blm or you don't believe in um the i'm sure you
believe in the slogan but you don't believe in
no i don't believe in slogan i think the slogan is
problematic black lives matter what does that mean
does that mean black lives matter more than white
lives does that mean that why do why black lives
in particular why not jewish lives matter why not
arabic lives matter surely all lives matter is the
first logo please there is no police brutality in
the uk and if there is it's mostly our males it's
not any particular uh racial demographic we've
imported u.s politics in that the u.s can handle
their own business someone will get involved in
that that's their thing but for people over here
to be protesting to defund the police and that
black lives matter seems very confused to me
yeah that's something which actually upset
me during the riots because i think in the uk
we're very racially diverse everybody's all sort
of just get on here um and then when the riots
were happening in america we started protesting
here black and white people going at it and i'm
like this is not how it happens in britain
black and white people don't go at it here
i mean yesterday was ascension day in the uk we
celebrated it in the church and the guy giving
the uh saying the prayers in my church said i want
to say a special prayer to remember george floyd
i'm thinking this guy he wasn't a saint
he's like it's almost been canonized as
and held up on a pedestal the guy was a criminal
he was a convict and he was a pretty bad guy
in the way he treated his his baby mother
and the drugs and the gun and all that stuff
i understand it was horrible what happened to
him but let's not pretend he was some kind of
hero let's not pretend he was a martyr and that's
what to again to bring that u.s politics over here
where i'm sat in a uk church a church of england
church hearing someone preaching about george
floyd it just it riles me up how much support
do you get when you talk about these things a
lot of support uh a lot of quiet sports a lot of
dms emails and letters people saying thank you for
saying what you say i can't say it because i get
fired oh that's awful that happens that's crazy
people feel like they're oppressed and they
are because it seems in the mainstream media
in politics all across the the public square the
woke opinions are the ones you hear but it's very
small minority they're just a very vocal minority
most people don't believe in that nonsense most i
believe that most people in this country believe
in common sense and british values but they're
afraid to speak up because if they stick their
head above the parapet it might get chopped off
to what extent do you feel that you have to
identify with a certain political party or
a narrative based on the colour of your
skin uh i don't i just i ignore all that
rubbish but i people want me to people want me
to say every time i speak up people either say
thank you for doing that and encouraging me and
i i agree with you or you're a grifter you know
who's either you're you're pirating what the white
master wants you to say or you're you're just
making this up for clicks and views or it cannot
possibly be that these are my opinions and these
this is my lived experience and these are always
the people that are all talking about this is
you know let's hear more lived experiences it's
always the people that are saying let's listen to
more ethnic minority voices but they don't want to
hear them if they contradict what they're saying i
believe in what i'm saying i see what i mean and
i mean what i say i think everyone should do that
but it really really gets on my nerves when people
assume that these aren't my opinions because why
that's racism i can't hold these opinions because
i happen to have brown skin that's your issue not
mine it's funny it's like modern day racism of
course it is but they don't see it how would you
how do you feel we go about changing that
because these people won't listen to you no
yeah because feelings have replaced
facts haven't they and it's all about how
someone feels and their anecdotal experience
i know i've used the term lived experience so
so often but that just means an anecdote it
means their personal anecdotes they are weighted
more heavily than evidence facts data statistics
and we need to flip that back around and say
actually if we want to make society a better
place we have to look at the big picture
we have to be evidence informed we have to look
at what's actually going on and that's the only
way we can solve these problems if we only listen
to the loudest voices we're not looking at where
the issue is what i'm trying to understand is
you mentioned it's all about control earlier
um let's um let's get into that what do you mean
it's about control who's controlling what and
what are they trying to control so for example
when joe biden says if you don't vote democrat
you ain't black that's so bad of course it's bad
i mean we recognize that's probably quite racist
yeah but the left would say actually yes because
the democrats are the party for black people and
the way they do that is that that's a whole
demographic of people that must vote for their
party in order to get them into power it's the
same over here with jeremy corbyn who said we will
unlock your potential as ethnic minorities i don't
need a politician to unlock my potential thank you
very much i work hard and i believe in meritocracy
and i'll get by on my own and i think on the right
we tend to believe in a hand up not a handout you
know helping someone help themselves yes on the
left it's more collectivism it's more the state
is responsible for you and you you're dependent
on the state and the state therefore must help you
and i think that's it's condescending because it
holds people down it holds people back and this
whole victimhood mentality is all that you know
if we tell people often enough that they are a
victim they'll start to believe it they'll start
to act like a victim and then they'll get stuck
in a rut and you'll say and then you can say look
these black people are victims it's like well
yes because you've spent so long telling them
they are that they're no longer trying to get out
of this rut so i totally agree with you and joe
biden also said something which really annoyed me
as a female he said something like i will be the
one to help women i'm like why do women need help
we're good isn't that kind of just like such a
godly mentality that he has of himself to
think that he's the savior of women and
or whatever it is um so yeah for me for me that's
it's such a such a bizarre way of doing things
um but they tell okay so the democrats the left
you know they preach that certain minorities or
certain groups are victims do you think they
genuinely think that they're victims or do you
think and i personally think this is the democrats
they tell them victims so that they can stay as
victims and they stay under the boot it's a bit of
both people like joe biden i think he knows what
he's doing if we look at things he's said in the
past he's been quite racist on a lot of occasions
however interestingly if you show people clips
of what he said they'll back him up unless you
take his face off it and play them the audio clip
that's racist so there's a there's a bias going
on there but there's two types of people there's
one type of person that is genuinely wanting to
help people but is misguided and thinks that the
left's approach is the right way and then there's
the more malicious person who wants to keep people
oppressed wants to keep people but down because
if people are dependent on you then that you're
they're going to give you their vote for example
the whole the whole welfare state system is set up
so that you know if you are dependent on the state
to give you your paycheck of course you're going
to vote for the party that's going to give you
the biggest paycheck that's just common sense so
it's it's detrimental to people's well-being you
know people want naturally to contribute people
want to be leading meaningful lives they don't
want to be stuck at home watching tv all day
waiting for the next welfare check that's not
natural so it's not natural but do you think i
see my thing is i think by design humans always
take the path of least resistance and so that's
why we're in the situation that we're in because
people don't want to go back to work after getting
you know their stimulus checks or their furlough
so i'm in like this two minds of of you know
people do want to feel empowered and i do think
you know when you make your own money and you're
empowered and you're feeling good you're eating
healthy you're feeling great everything's going
really well in your life that's when you're most
happiest but i don't think people want to put in
the work that will make you most happiest because
we like to take the path of least resistance
yeah it's not in their interest to do so
right so i often talk about the reason i'm a
conservative because my mother was a single parent
raising me and my sister on her own working
multiple jobs to feed us but she would have been
better off at home a lot of her friends were at
home on benefits they were making more money than
she was but she wanted to contribute she wanted
to show me that working hard is how you get by and
i'm so thankful that she did that because that's
where i got my work ethic from but it wouldn't
make sense for her to do it and like i say most
people didn't why would you put the extra effort
in if you're better off not doing it that's why
the welfare state is criminal i totally agree with
you um and it's so funny because people often say
that's so heartless um but i think the heartless
thing is is making someone dependent on you and
not teaching them how to save themselves it's a
misunderstanding of heartlessness and kindness
you know as a teacher i often experience this
i'm a strong disciplinarian i think if a child is
misbehaving you give them a disciplinary measure
you give them an attention or something and
people say you know if they're coming from a
deprived background or they're an ethnic minority
or something you can't expect them to do the same
amounts of homework you know they've got
issues going on at home they've got a hard life
be a bit more relaxed with them and like actually
that no that's not a kindness that's holding them
back because if you say oh poor jimmy you don't
have to do your homework because you've got a hard
situation you know your dad's left your mom and
your mum's drinking if you go down that route then
let jimmy off from his homework he doesn't reach
the same levels as the rest of his classmates he's
so you're literally holding him back so he's
he's getting less knowledge than everyone else
therefore he's less empowered when he leaves
school to get a good job and to make a good
life for himself what feels like a kindness
is actually that is heartlessness to when you
truly love someone you give them you tell them the
truth or you give them boundaries that's what love
is love is a kindness in in a in a boundary and a
bounded structure of support it's not about giving
people the freedom to destroy themselves tough
love yeah tough love yeah warm strict yeah yeah
what other areas do you feel that um wokism is um
infiltrating um you know you mentioned trans um
so that's like gender now we have more than uh
two genders um i know you've spoken about meat
so what other areas do you feel like the wokism
is uh infiltrating it's everywhere it's everywhere
we look it's tiring sometimes like just living a
normal life everywhere you go is wokeness you know
in the church you walk in the church sometimes
you've got the rainbow flag on the altar now
instead of a cross you go into schools it's the
same situation and they're saying you know young
boys can wear skirts now as well as well as the
girls because they don't want to offend anybody
um tell me an issue of an area of life and
i'll tell you where the workless is because
it's everywhere okay so you spoke about meat um
i saw an interview did recently you were talking
about you went to this talk or something
in oxford where they compared me to meat
to white supremacy can you just explain that for
us so that was michaela peterson debating this
i'm trying to be charitable here this woman let's
just use her uh her that adjective because i
don't want to use anything else because i'm just
according to ad hominems this person was talking
about so michael and peterson obviously she has
a meat-eating diet she's a big carnivore and it's
fantastic it works for her this other person was
saying that uh we should all give up meat because
meat is racist sexist colonialist um i can't
remember what other histories and she said i i
had to walk out i just couldn't stomach it because
at some point you have to say look this is not a
debate in good faith this is there's nothing we
can debate with here because this is pure lunacy
and i'm not going to entertain it i'm done
with you um i spoke to jordan peterson about
it afterwards because he was laughing because
obviously he could see me just storm out
he said you know i would have done the same but i
was supporting michaela but i think we just have
to say to these people i'm not going to engage
with your linus anymore that is you know you're
on a different plane that's ridiculous there is no
point that we can there's no common ground we can
meet on here but they do believe it though so what
i'm trying to understand i'm trying to understand
the rationale right do they believe it though or
are they trying to tick every box because they
think oh we're in a university campus excuse
me we're in university campus we'll talk about
racism we'll talk about sexism we'll talk about
colonialism we'll talk about the other isms and
this and then everyone will love us is it about
wanting people to like you some people genuinely
believe it otherwise we won't be at this point
i mean i personally think i mean people might
call me a conspiracy theorist that's cool but
i personally think it's because meat gives you
strength right meat is good protein and helps you
build muscle and you know keeps you strong and fit
and when you're strong and fit you can fight
yeah yeah fight whatever it is whether it's
so they don't want us to fight back because yes
yeah you ever thought about that no that's deep
i don't believe in the term conspiracy theorist
anymore by the way because the conspiracy theories
over the last two years have been spoiler
alerts and it will come true so what do you
think about that then i mean there must be a
reason why they're bright and because it's not
it's not just me you're not giving them too
much credit no i don't think they're smarter
than they are well i don't think it comes from
the woman who was debating michaela i think it
comes from a higher place perhaps yes perhaps
claus schwab type world economic forum places
um because you know by 2030 you'll have
your or you'll have nothing and be happy
i won't though i wish we had a second amendment
like what they have in the united states a way to
protect ourselves from these terraneous dictators
well let's talk about that because um recently by
the time this airs the unfortunate shooting that
happened in texas will be a few weeks ago now
um but that's interesting as a british person you
feel that you would like the right to bear arms
yeah it's biblical you know christ said to his
apostles get yourself a sword he said if you don't
have one sell it sell your robes get yourself a
sword i think do you think that would work here
here in the uk it's a different issue but we used
to have the right to bear arms i mean it was still
until quite recently the law that we had
to practice uh bow and arrow shooting
just in case to protect the nation but we have to
have a way of protecting ourselves from the state
and i worry about that especially over the last
couple of years the way that the whole west
or the western world some including you
know new zealand and australia in this
the way they've gone back on civil liberties and
decided that actually governments have the power
to control your personal life you know we used to
say an englishman's home is his castle it's up to
me who i invite into my house but no not anymore
the government could say actually you only allowed
so many people in your house you're not allowed
to touch them you can't hug your loved ones
you can't go outside of your house or if you can
only for once a day and only for five minutes or
whatever that is too much no government should
have that much say over someone's life and if
they're willing to do that over something that is
essentially a cold or a flu what are they willing
to do for worse situations and is this a test run
for something else i don't know i'm stepping into
what i said i don't believe in conspiracy theories
but i'm stepping into that ground now because
until two years ago i never thought in my wildest
dreams that something like that would happen that
we'd follow the ideology of communist china
and i know that italy did it first and we'll
say we copied to italy but we're essentially
copying china why we if we believe that they
are a great evil if we believe that they are a
force to be reckoned with in this world and we
should be fighting against their values why are
we copying them i totally agree with you um i'm
gonna we're gonna get into all of that actually
um but i wanna go i wanna focus a little bit more
on the right to protect yourself um because how do
we protect ourselves here in the uk i mean even in
the us guns didn't protect them from medicine
mandates i don't like to hit the red flag on
the algorithm with the words so medicine medicine
mandates um guns didn't protect them so how do we
protect ourselves from tyrannical governments how
do we i suppose it's all about numbers isn't it
we have to remember that we are the majority we
have to stand up saying that you know in the uk
we had the biggest protest ever against the war in
iraq and it still went ahead tony blair still went
ahead with that war even though the vast majority
people didn't want it so i'm not i'm not sure if
a majority even works anymore i have honestly no
idea how we stop these these things it's i lose
sleep over it it's the idea that there are a group
of elites meeting in davos right now as we record
this deciding our fates and a lot of people think
we're crazy for believing that but you know they
literally published their ideas this monkey pops
nonsense for example last year there was a a war
game set up what if monkey pox becomes the next
pandemic and they a war game like an actual like
on the playstation i think like global leaders got
together to plan what what they do if monkey box
walking like they play play it out they sit there
around the table like a like um what the pretend
uh thing is called um and if you look at the
timetable they said it would drop in what was it
um may 2022 and i mean the timeline hit with what
we're seeing now and that we we see everywhere
in the press at the moment is this monkey
pop situation which the symptoms aren't as
severe as smallpox it's very closely linked to
chickenpox as well in fact it's the same vaccine
for monkeybox and smallpox and the numbers we're
seeing are negligible but then media is reporting
it so heavily and we've got bill gates came out
a year ago saying you know um a pox might be the
next pandemic and next time we'll take it more
seriously and next time governments will have to
restrict liberties sooner and faster and harder
as i'm like if these leaders are saying this and
they're predicting this and it's all coming true
bear in mind smallpox has been eradicated for what
70 years or so and suddenly we've got a version
of that coming out after the elites have predicted
that particular virus spreading amongst us all
of these things can't always become instances
do you think that um these elites world
governments world economic forum do you
think that they overplayed their hand throughout
covert i think they've got away with it throughout
covert i think there's still a vast majority of
people in this country are because people are
invested in that in the in the the medicine that
they took now so people have to believe that it
worked even though the fires a data drop showed
that actually it wasn't 95 efficacy it was 12
efficacy and after like a week it went down to
one percent so the thing doesn't work it doesn't
do anything at best at worst it has more adverse
effects than any other vaccine we've ever issued
uh in our recorded history uh you know they
tried it with tamiflu in 2009 but thankfully
at that point the media called it out and said
this virus isn't spreading as rapidly it's not
as dangerous and the vaccine for it doesn't
work therefore this is a major scam by the
pharmaceutical industry and because the media
called it out it got halted this time around
the government got on the phone to the media
um and gave them words of cash uh called it uh
what was the word for it uh some kind
of supplement to it to support them
um throughout a lockdown and all that situation so
the media were funded directly by the government
and this the officials were not on the phone while
the prime minister was calling around the major
um news corporations and you know i've worked i
work in the news and i've seen the conversations
that i had and the topics that you're not
allowed to discuss at the same time they
change the offcom ruling ofcom is the independent
body which regulates the media over here to what
offcom said you can no longer question or
undermine public health policy you can no longer
question it what that's outrageous and you know
on certain radio stations that i used to frequent
the lawyer said look just don't touch the topic
what radio station i'm not gonna name them but
these are ones that we would think are
fighting on on our side lbc probably
if if the lawyers are that protective because
they don't want to get shut down so who is who
is fighting for the general people who is who's
on our side you and i alternative news oh yeah
joe rogan yeah yeah um okay so i tried to shut
him down exactly and elon musk what happened
when elon musk said we'll fight for free
speech all of these uh these instances come
out of apparent sexual abuse and like oh that's
coincidence interesting timing he predicted it
um you said you don't know how we solved
this and you said it keeps you up at night
so for those that don't know the way that you and
i met was through twitter and we were talking um
because because of everything that was going on in
canada when justin trudeau um he had his medicine
mandates and the truckers were protesting and i
was very vocal because bitcoin and i don't mean
to be a cliche honestly um but for me i agree
with everything that you said and for me and for
my community we truly believe that bitcoin is the
solution because it's all about money right you
even said it you said that the government gave
the media money so it's all about the money to
start off with you will owe nothing and be happy
because they'll own everything the money so if
you don't own if if they don't have control
over the money then they lose control so to
what extent do you have a knowledge about bitcoin
thank you for not saying bitcoin fixes this well
we'll get that we'll get there calvin i do think
it is part of the solution decentralized money
and decentralized power go hand in hand this whole
idea that the government wants a digital central
currency uh where they can essentially control
where we spend our money is the most dangerous
thing i can think of the bank of england says we
need to have the power to prevent people spending
money in the wrong places we need to have the
control the wrong places exactly oh what meat for
example meat is not good for you it's carcinogenic
you cannot buy meat and that's it you're done
green causes uh you can't buy plane tickets
because it's bad for the environment of course
the elite will still swung around
in the private jets as we've seen
they're all flying to davos to talk
about climate change it's the hypocrisy
but yeah i think bitcoin could help us along
the way it's a good test case but does it have
that grassroots movement to get going into you
know you can sit around and talk about it quite
eloquently and articulate it very well on your
podcast but if i was to say to my grandmother
bitcoin it fixes this would i be able to put that
across in a way that she would understand do you
know what i mean it's got to be like i just paid
i got a cab here i paid the guy in cash and he
was like so thankful that i gave him cash and not
tried to use a card but that's how we keep these
things alive but everyone understands cash we
understand that it's a promise of payment and that
we don't have to go into the into the whole
fiat system but we get that handing over that
note means that i have a tangible amount that
i can cash in as a bank somebody say something
really cold-hearted go on um just because i i'm
into the facts okay so elon musk said something
really interesting and he said um i can't i'm
gonna try paraphrase i can't fully remember but
it was something like he said like death is good
because without the death of the older generation
we wouldn't change and we wouldn't innovate
right that's what he was saying so because if
everyone stayed alive and the older generation
remains nothing would change because you get
to a certain age whereby you're set in your
ways you can't teach an old dog new tricks
um you know in the bitcoin community we
laugh at warren buffett because he just
can't understand bitcoin and it's it's funny um
and so that's why it's the younger generation
who are more open-minded and open to change that
are able to bring about these new things now the
interesting thing is the fact that you and i are
talking the reason that's interesting is because
you're from the politics sphere although i'm
super into politics i'm from the bitcoin sphere
but we're meeting for a reason yeah
it's because our worlds are colliding
and so i think it's people like you who are going
to bring about the next bitcoin revolution and
the next adoption of bitcoin okay i do worry
about that i know you said you were going to
be cold-hearted and you know you're playing it
off a bit but i do worry about that because it's
the older generations that hold us back a bit
and that's important because we can't progress
too quickly and as much as i love elon musk for
being a free speech absolutist and i hope he
does buy twitter i know he's playing games with
him at the moment but if he does it'd be great
but he's also a massive liberal
a massive liberal progressive
i don't agree with his politics you know he he
would be he would be big into transhumanism for
example and i think that's a dangerous line and i
think actually he'd probably have a lot in common
with the wef lot on that on that front as in they
can't wait for us to all be shipped in some way or
another it's another form of control and he sees
it as exciting and innovative and people like
that you know he's well intentioned but people
like that are what lead us down a straight path
so we do have to be careful and not this is
why i don't hear a worship as much as i think
it's fantastic what he's doing in some ways we
have to be so careful on the speed at which we
process progress not just in trans transhumanism
but also in artificial intelligence and all of
these areas of digital digital world which is why
having the older generation say actually no i just
want to use my five pound note to buy my pack
of [__] cigarettes for the americans nothing
that's such a good thing that's such a novelty no
i understand and i agree with you um and that's
funny because i think there's a meme online which
is like bill gates wants to put a chip in your
brain no way elon musk yeah let's have a chip
in my brain yeah because yeah he i do believe
he is well intentioned um but no i'm totally
with you but i don't think bitcoin is that
no no it's not you know and i think that i've
spoken to a lot of different people um who are
quite conservative in the uk and they they tend
to be interested in bitcoin but i do think it's
it's you guys who are going to bring about the
next grassroots as you put it because you have
the libertarians you have the people like myself
who are very interested in bitcoin the bitcoiners
um but as more things happen like justin trudeau
freezes people's bank accounts because they don't
want to take certain medicines people like you
i do believe we'll drive we'll drive the next
we'll push the next wave well that's very kind
i think it comes down to convenience so the the
analogy i always look at is you know i spent
a lot of time in america and i i know you're
going there soon and it's just over there is very
different over here and the way that we pay for
pay for things the transactions are different so
i'm always surprised when i go to the west coast
and how difficult it is to just use my card or
you know just to swipe or my my phone often in
the uk i know i'm a big supporter of cash but
often i can leave my house with just my phone
and not be stressed because i know that i can
get on a bus and get a taxi and go in the shop
and buy a chocolate bar i can go to a cafe buy a
drink and go out to a restaurant i do whatever i
like i can go clothes shopping and i just go in
america it's so difficult for some reason the
people that invented all this technology just
they're so reticent and it's taken them a long
time you know things like square have come around
and then there was apple pay but only in certain
places and it's like what are you doing it just
feels so backwards but of course that like you
know the rate of progress is important but over
why i'm talking about that is because with bitcoin
there isn't that element of convenience i can't
just nip into my local shop and say can i just
wire you bitcoin there's there needs to be a jump
there that it makes it easier for the shopkeeper
and easier for the person coming in or more
convenient for them to use bitcoin than it did
to pull out a five-point note and the mobile
phone or the contact list is more convenient
and that's why they're winning on that
front but bitcoin isn't quite at that
place yet yeah i do agree with you i think that um
it's all about convenience people would sacrifice
democracy and all that stuff for convenience it's
yeah it's the lifelong tell um the community is
working on it and there are different things that
you can do um there are different intermediaries
i mean you mentioned square there's cash app
um in america which actually accepts bitcoin
um so there's loads of different things but i
don't know i just sort of think like politically
as from like a decentralized standpoint
as the world becomes more authoritarian
i mean you mentioned cbdc's central bank digital
currencies um and actually at the world economic
forum um in davos i think it was this week um so
they were talking about them and somebody actually
said i don't know who was but she was on stage
she actually said if we do implement this like
china have done um if we do implement this then
we're going to need a new human rights bill
okay to ensure because because of the tyrannical
potential yeah so then the question is who's to
say that they'll stick to that the same way
they didn't stick to the nuremberg code when
it came to the vaccines oh absolutely well they
won't do because it won't be in their interest
will it so what protection do we have it comes
back to how do we protect ourselves from the
state and i still don't have the answer
to that bitcoin is the answer i'm sorry
yeah okay if bitcoin fixes it show me how i'm
i'm i'm open to the idea that bitcoin does fix it
i'm just not seeing it yet yeah i mean because
i i am a supporter of the second amendment
um that we we uh touched on earlier um it's
just like because everything's becoming digital
it's like to what extent are guns going to be
helpful like i said in new york it didn't really
help them well the israelis do tend to have
a better idea around that than the americans
i think you know the israelis did you think
yeah in what way as in you know the teachers
will have guns in the security guards
oh i see yeah there are other approaches
yeah but i mean like that didn't protect them from
uh the green card you had to have in it and yeah
so with all of that in mind um you know my answer
is bitcoin um where do you think we go from here
in terms of you know what culture infiltrating the
church of england um you know meat being this this
this white supremacy type of food you know where
do you think we go from here um we just all have
to start speaking up and i think you're right in
that bitcoin for example you mentioned canada a
few times when they started blocking the bank
accounts of the protesters and then we saw the
bitcoin people saying well you know we can donate
via brick coins so that was a great solution so
coming up with positive solutions to help the
problems that we're facing is good but in general
just normal everyday folk need to not be afraid
of being cancelled you need to stand up whether
it's saying no i enjoy a stake and i'm not a white
supremacist there are two genders man and woman
and you know i know the truth you can lie to my
face but that's your issue not mine um or whether
it's saying that you know as a white person i'm
not a pr an oppressor as a black person i'm not
a victim i just own the truth and just speak
up and if you know they cannot cancel all of us
i'm also interested in the fact that
um just sort of going back a sec you
didn't come from a religious background um so i'm
interested i know you sort of said that your mum
and seeing her work hard is what gave you that um
i guess that conservative mindset of working hard
and wanting to build something um but where does
the religious part come in i think i've always had
a knowledge of god that he existed i think we're
all born with that i think we all have some innate
gut instinct that is something bigger than
ourselves um some people deny it some people
silence it and push it aside but i think we
all we're all born with that it's linked to our
to our instinct it's linked to our conscience um
but it took me a long long time to find religion
and it was only when i found it when i found the
faith that i realized that's what i've always been
searching for um to articulate it in in a way
that people might feel uncomfortable with but
it was only when i had an experience with
christ that i realized that he's the one
i've been searching for my whole life and
that was special for me and that changed my
whole outlook on life and made me decide that
actually i need to center my life around christ
and so my politics comes from that my work comes
from that everything i do comes from that at least
i try to live a christian life as best i can i'm
interested because um religion is very much about
faith right um arguably maybe you could tell me
i'm wrong but it's not so much facts it's faith
um and you and you know how being a
conservative we're more interested in
facts over feelings um so how do you
navigate life with christ at the center of it
but you know you're you're basing you're basing
your life off of faith rather than facts so i see
them as the same thing so i see the problem with
the left is that everything's become subjective so
everything everyone owns their own individual
truths everyone creates their own realities
and expects all of us to live in their reality
which is actually a fantasy it's not a reality
um when someone says they're gender fluid or that
they are now identifying as a horse i don't see
that as an objective truth i see that as their
subjective fantasy whereas within the faith we're
giving we're given a book that is directed by
god is the word of god himself and that is an
objective truth that should shape our reality and
we should be focusing on heading towards you so
even if you're not christian i talk about you
know the enlightenment is the pursuit of knowledge
and as a christian we have the pursuit of the
universal truth and jesus christ said he was
the way the truth and the life so we're looking
to center everything around him so it's an anchor
it's a point that you can always draw to and
if someone says actually this is the truth now
you say no i've still got it it's it's it's fixed
it's static it's objective okay and like i said i
don't call myself a religious person but i
would definitely say i'm spiritual because
what does that mean it means that i believe
in a higher power um and i don't know what i
would call it so i don't know if i would call it
god the universe um but i definitely believe in
like a kind loving energy um so my my question
is like how are you so sure that god is real
because i've had experiences where i have been
touched in my heart by god i've felt his presence
um and when i read the bible it reads true to me
but i think it's so important the path that you're
on i mean we all have our own faith journeys
but when you say you believe in a faith or you
believe in a power bigger than others i think
that just that starting point is so important
because that's something i find that on the left
many on the left the work people don't have and
it's a sense of accountability it's a sense of we
are not the most important thing in the universe
i think in their in their eyes they often are
whereas we would say that there's something bigger
than us and that's more important whether that's
community or god you know having that sense of
of otherness it's grounding it's it's a humanity
and you said it's because you've had experiences
do you think that's because you are chosen
in some way or do you think it's or do you
think you're just spiritually more open i don't
know like why do you have your experience versus
somebody else like why don't i say i feel my heart
has been touched by god like why do you say that
i suppose it's just you haven't needed
it that's but what happens in our lives
directs us down a path and sometimes we need a bit
of a kick up the back side and sometimes we don't
and you might be on a journey to get to where
you need to be without need without any prompting
or there might be something that happens later in
your life that prompts you and you and opens your
eyes to god um i can't i can't really comment
on that but my own personal experience is that
whenever i've needed god whenever i've said
prayers for something those prayers have been
answered or at least i've felt that they've
been answered and that's been important to me
that's really interesting i'm always interested
to hear people's perspective on god and
i know because obviously you center your
life around um the religion so what so
what are you doing now essentially um i know
you're at gb news um when will you become a priest
are you still becoming a priest i will um at gb
news i'm launching a new show on faith and family
nice very soon hopefully congrats thank you um and
i'll be ordained next month and i'll be a priest
in um well the gaffcom movement which is growing
in north america it's much smaller over here what
does that stand for um well it's the global
anglican's future conference but it's about
being an orthodox anglican so i would
say you know people say why have you
left the church of england i would
say the church of england has left me
i i think it's left the faith behind and addressed
a new new religion but there are lots of anglicans
around the world that hold dear to the
anglican formulas of you know the bible
and the book of common prayer and the 39 articles
so i'm joining their group being validly ordained
i'm going to set up a church in london very
very soon and you're welcome to come along
i will do um yeah so i'm going to get on with my
public ministry on gv news and my parish ministry
in london that's amazing major congrats on all
of that um do you would you say part of that
um in any way is maybe in any way do you feel
like you would like to undo the woke the woke-ism
that's infiltrated the united kingdom do you feel
like that's something you're now going to dedicate
a little bit of time to as a priest no it's too
tiring it's it's draining i think instead of
trying to undo the workness i'm trying i'm going
to try at least offer an alternative um you know
my church will be a space that is rooted in
faith rooted in christ rooted in objective
truth and if people want to escape the madness of
the world around them they're welcome to come here
okay amazing and where can people find you and
follow you um so i have a website evangelical
evangelicalcatholics.com people can put their
email address in and once the church is planted
i'll let them know uh but i'm on all the
social media platforms at calvin robinson
calvin i want to thank you so much it's
been so fascinating hearing your perspective
and it's it's really just so refreshing to speak
to people who see reality um and are also brave
enough to speak up um with regards to everything
that's going on at the moment well thank you keep
fighting the good fights always thank you i'll
hold you in my prayers thank you likewise guys
thank you so much for watching if you enjoyed this
episode please don't forget to hit the like button
and hit subscribe so you can support the channel
and you never miss a video and also a massive
thank you to our sponsors as always bitmex and
step finance because without both of them we want
to be able to bring you such important content
we'll see you next week malaya high or pancho
you